what is up what is good how you living
how you feeling how you doing here's the
thing i know how you're living
i know how you're feeling and i know how
you're doing because the draft
it is upon us and there's one last thing
that i need to get
out of connor rogers brain it's not
about instant impact rookies it's not
about
the late sleeper it's mock draft time
i need to know who connor thinks is
going at
every single pick we've done this for
now eight weeks
happy to wrap it up and i cannot wait to
sit at the desk
with connor rogers and the key to leave
and our cast of friends
for draft night with br gridiron it's
going to be a blast
connor mocks are always different in the
intent
of the macker so is this who you believe
the team
should take who they will take how did
you make this mock
it's a nice balance of both lefko right
you're gonna have some trades that
might seem like out of nowhere but
nothing too crazy and then you're also
gonna have
the staples that we know right we're not
gonna reinvent the wheel at one or two
and there's some guys that might sneak
in here so a nice balance of both and
we'll explain each
all right i do see there is one trade
and we will get to that
but let's start off first pick in the
draft the jacksonville jaguars select
trevor lawrence i mean no surprise here
right we know this is happening let's
not get cute with it
he's going to be the future of their
franchise he's somebody that we've heard
about
for a really really long time since he
was a true freshman and
really the offensive player of that
national title game as a true freshman
they've built their entire offseason
around him lefko they went out and
gave big money to urban meyer trevor
lawrence is coming out of a very college
offense a lot of screens a lot of quick
one reads
and urban is gonna have to bring some of
that stuff to the pro game so i think
when you look at it
trevor lawrence is poised to have a huge
impact he's a great runner
he's a great leader they have some
pieces down there already they have more
picks to get more pieces around him
trevor lawrence is about as much of a
no-brainer
at number one at the quarterback
position as you can get
their first pick in the first round new
york jets your new york jets select i'm
going quickly through the first two
because i feel like everybody knows
absolutely and this is zach wilson and
another one that i know
there's a little bit more debate here
right you can argue for justin fields
you can even make an
argument for trey lance who i think is a
phenomenal prospect i think all four of
these quarterbacks are top five overall
prospects
but zach wilson is the guy they've sold
themselves on and he fits everything
they want to do that lightning quick
release
the ball placement down the field they
went out and gave corey davis
a ton of money in free agency to
understand that they need
above the rim contested catch players
him and denzel mims that can go up
and win the football for these vertical
throws from zack wilson
and they just love the timing how quick
he can get the ball out
the decision making the athleticism mike
lafleur is coming over from san
francisco you're going to see some
elements of the san francisco offense
the tennessee offense green bay a wide
zone running game
so the jets they reset the financial
clock right the quarterback clock they
align the gm
the head coach and the new quarterback
all together and that's what led to zach
wilson being this selection and an
exciting one for new york jets fans i
can't say that enough
zach wilson can be a superstar in this
league
now the third pick in the draft the one
that everybody's got circled and
everybody's wondering
who did the niners trade all those picks
up to get
this is connor rogers pick connor who do
the niners take
yeah it's got a little bit of my flavor
on it because i know everyone thinks
this will be mac jones but we're gonna
go trey lance here and i'm just obsessed
with this fit for
both sides left go i look at trey lance
does such a nice job taking care of the
football
a big-bodied athlete that can run over
defensive backs in the open field
i think the accuracy will get a lot
better over time
love his leadership abilities i mean
this is someone that threw
28 touchdowns and no interceptions as a
19 year old
red red shirt freshman starter in the
fcs so there will be some growing pains
there
but this is the landing spot to do that
they have jimmy garoppolo if they want
he could start out the season
and then you can work trey lance in at
his own pace
but the upside with trey lance is
superstar
that's not the case with mac jones that
ceiling does not exist i don't care who
tells you how smart he is the ball
placement all of those things
this is an nfl where mobility and
athleticism matters trey lance has all
of those things
but he also has all the intangibles as
well so
i think he can grow into an incredible
middle of the field thrower
in kyle shanahan's offense he gave up
three first round picks to get here
now swing for the fences don't start
laying down buns or
choking up on the bat and taking the
contact swings swing some of the fences
and go get trey lance
i would go mac jones in mine mainly
because i look at kyle shanahan and i go
matt ryan matt chobb kirk cousins
that's kind of the vibe i think but
listen this is connor rogers he's the
expert he's been doing this for 365.
i'm just here trying to get the
knowledge so if trey lance goes three
atlanta is then on the clock at four
what do you see happening at four
now a lot of things right they can go
penne sewell
and kick somebody inside and start penne
at left tackle
they can go kyle pitts and say hey matt
ryan we're giving you this chance to get
that super bowl with us especially after
restructuring his deal
now i think the best move long term for
the franchise a new gm
a new head coach is trading this
selection this selection can be worth a
lot because that fourth quarterback on
the board
has a lot of value and i think the team
that should come up and get that
quarterback
is the denver broncos because then it
works for both sides atlanta only goes
to nine
they have a lot of options of what they
can do at nine solve a lot of their
needs get a really talented player
and they're still going to get a lot of
picks i think at a minimum this would
cost the broncos
two second round picks maybe they can
even squeeze a future first rounder out
of them to come up
and you get justin fields imagine when
you imagine justin fields in the broncos
offense and i know we've done this on
this show for a long time
the fit is great his accuracy his power
arm
his mobility you have cortland sutton
that's coming back he can work down the
field
jerry judy everything intermediate you
have kj
hamler you know they can run the ball
the offensive line has gotten better
over time
justin fields can take this offense to
the next level
and if you really don't think he's ready
to play which i think is nonsense i
think he is
you can build a quarterback competition
between him and drew lock and see where
it goes there's nothing wrong with
searching for your quarterback still
throughout this process
but justin fields is somebody you can
feel strongly about for the future of
your franchise
and that jump from nine to four is not
crazy okay
so now we have a very active top four
number five
is the bengals and i have a feeling that
you're gonna go with the recent rumors
from the last three weeks is it gonna be
jamar chase
yeah let's keep this one simple right
you go out you've already seen this
playbook before between him and joe
burrow that led to a national title game
now i understand the the need for
offensive line but i think jonah
williams is serviceable at left tackle
get a rare wide receiver this is the
best one we've seen in the last couple
of draft classes that
is truly a mismatch problem nobody will
say this except me
i think jamar chase is a bigger mismatch
problem for defensive coordinators than
kyle pitts
this guy was 19 beating nfl cornerbacks
so i know it seems crazy to say that but
that's what i think i think he's great
after the catch i think he's a good
route runner i think he's phenomenal in
contested catch situations
get joe burrow his guy this is really
now you have a foundation in place in
cincinnati with him and chase for the
next five
six seven years maybe even longer it's
like matt ryan julio all over again that
kind of vibes here it would really
really excite me
with joe barrow's accuracy and a top
three wide receiver of jamar chase t
higgins and tyler boyd that is a very
athletic and dynamic
offense we want to see joe burrow get
healthy if he comes back and he's got
his guy jamar chase
he'll be happy as well number six the
dolphins traded back from that top three
spot originally went back to 12 came
back up to six
who do they get at six they get kyle
pitts and this works out perfectly for
them i think when they made this move
with your eagles left go they came back
up saying we need an
offensive dynamic player for our young
quarterback we bet the franchise on
we think chase or pitts will make it to
this spot well guess what you played it
right pitts is there
now you have him and gaseki working the
middle of the field for a quarterback
that needs those middle yes they are
going to run the scene they're seeing
beaters they can run by linebackers they
can
beat defensive backs in contested catch
situations pitts is very good
after the catch great in the red zone
tua is a nice player but he has his
limitations so you they know they need
to help him out
and pitts is this mix of you're getting
a little wide receiver you're getting a
little tight end
you hope he as he gets older he'll be a
20 year old rookie you hope he grows as
a blocker as well to really get that run
game going too
so this worked out perfectly for miami
okay now we get to pick number seven the
detroit lions when i hear
people talk about mock drafts nobody
ever thinks about the lions we start
getting excited about carolina
what would denver do at nine detroit
whether it's dan campbell or jared goff
there's not a lot of excitement so where
do you see detroit going at seven
well i'm thinking about you detroit
lions and part of it is because i have
to but also part of it is because you do
matter picking in the top ten here
and this is gonna surprise people but i
don't care devonte smith at seven
you've already made the commitment to
jared goff
as crazy as it is you've made that
commitment
lefko have you seen after kenny goliday
left who he's left throwing the ball to
you need her number one it is
it will not work besides tj hawkinson
you need
more devonta smith is a number one wide
receiver i don't care that he weighed
166
he'll play bigger than that in the nfl
he dominated the sec
he helps out quarterbacks he can go up
and high point the football
he's great in opening he's great in
space creating his own yards
he doesn't drop anything we know what
goth is he's a pocket passer
who has really good ball placement but
isn't going to create on his own he
needs guys that are gonna get open
immediately and also help out the
quarterback
that's devante smith right here and this
is a situation where you're in a good
spot to move out and i'll explain that
later and still get devonte smith
but i just think this fit and match is
too good to pass up
just for people's awareness brashad
perryman tyrell williams and khalif
raymond are the top three wide receivers
in detroit
the oc there is anthony lynn and so with
dan campbell and anthony lynn
they're likely going to want players
that are no nonsense think about that
coaching staff
devonte smith super professional makes
sense from a personality standpoint as
well
then we get to number eight carolina
panthers
they get sam darnold who do they get at
number eight
penney sewell and they make out like
bandits here right we know they have a
million wide receivers they have
christian mccaffrey
you've traded for sam darnold then
you're on long-term contracts there
where you feel like you could have taken
that risk
i still see a need here at left tackle
you have a really really good right
tackle and taylor motown that got the
franchise tag
now you have two bookends at tackle for
sam darnold you can run the football you
can get the outside run game working
with sewell's athleticism you know he
can keep sam
upright and pass protection these are
things that darnold
never really had with the new york jets
even when they drafted mackay bechten
he was phenomenal but it was too late in
the process and the offensive line had
other holes
and they didn't have the same weapons
that the panthers have joe
brady would be working with an
incredible incredible offense and that's
going to put a lot of pressure on sam to
succeed with this town around him
but this is giving him a chance and this
is by far the best player available my
number two overall player
on the big board current left tackle
there is greg little they also have
cameron irving so now suddenly you have
a pretty stable
four rotation where not as much pressure
is on those former draft picks that
maybe haven't panned out as much let's
take a look
at the top eight and see how connor had
this one fleshed out
trevor lawrence zach wilson 1-2 makes
sense connor goes with his guy
trey lance at number three broncos trade
from nine to four with atlanta to take
justin fields
jamar chase to the bengals kyle pitts to
the dolphins
little surprise devonta smith to the
lions at seven and panthers with a steal
at eight of all of these picks connor
who would get your best grade on draft
night if they pulled the trigger
i think it would be justin fields the
broncos because i love that aggressive
nature to go up and get a franchise
quarterback and one that's been
really over scrutinized over evaluated
throughout this process so he would get
it on just the pure aggressiveness
but the best values the panthers penney
sewell at eight he's the number two
overall player
he's a franchise left tackle he could do
everything you ask of him that's the one
that i'd look at and go man
talk about building a foundation whether
sam works out or not you know sue will
be there for the next 10 years
all right so the falcons trade with the
broncos from four down to nine
they are on the clock connor the falcons
select
jalen phillips from miami maybe the
biggest surprise that we'll get in the
mock draft i guess but when you look at
phillips
things have changed he's always had top
10 talent he's always had it he had to
medically retire
after concussions at ucla he's rebuilt
his career at miami i've heard the
interviews have been really really good
everybody feels good about jalen
phillips again to what he was expected
to be
he's the most talented edge pass rusher
in this draft
honestly without the injuries in college
if he had a normal college career
we might be talking about not exactly
chase young but somewhat close to it he
has that much talent so
when you look at it for the falcons they
have a huge need on the edge
you moved back you've got a lot of draft
capital for the future
and now you've got a top flight pass
rusher that can win with speed to the
outside and turn the corner
long arms great length good get off can
beat double teams against the run
can really ask whatever you need of him
in any role stand up hand in the dirt
i know this pick is going to surprise
people and it might take a little
warming up to
but if jalen phillips does stay healthy
i really think he can be a star a
double-digit sac guy
year after year right now dante fowler
jr really the only pass rusher on that
falcons roster
the only thing i worry about for falcons
fans super athlete
acc they just hope it's not vic beasley
again number 10
the dallas cowboys who is dallas and
jerry jones and steven jones selecting
the pick you've heard about for a long
time and that's patrick certain the
second
you get yourself your starting corner
you might be able to move out of this
pick and still get that corner but let's
not get too cute with it
let's go get the guy that could start on
the outside for them
a good long press corner with ball
skills
he loves coming downhill to stop the run
a really aggressive player but also a
very smart player
tons of experience covering top flight
wide receivers
this is a plug-and-play pick for dallas
and boy do they need it at the
cornerback position you can make the
argument here
for rashaan slater rebuild your
offensive line but i just think this one
makes
way too much sense for them there's been
a ton of buzz around it
if kyle pitts or penne sewell doesn't
fall this far this is the pick i expect
all right he would join jordan lewis and
travon diggs who had some sparks last
year
11 is the new york giants we are in the
middle of an nfc east run who do the g
men take
they capitalized on that early
quarterback run and have a player fall
to them it's rashaan slater you need
help on the offensive line still
and this is a really a nice you know
double dipping kind of pick
if we're gonna assume andrew thomas and
matt work
out a tackle for now slater can kick
inside and play guard and you have a
huge hole there with kevin zeitler gone
at guard and slater can do it at a
really high level my cops are him were
dwayne brown and tristan worf
so now if one of the tackles doesn't
work out in the future
slater is your future franchise tackle
at either side he played right tackle
for two years he played left tackle for
one
three-year starter super pro ready can
climb to the second level and help that
run game for sequon barkley
this might not be the sexy flashy pick
but this is the right pick for the new
york giants especially with jalen
phillips off the board already i know
they need pass rusher
they could take another receiver but
this is your safe pick and now daniel
jones
he's almost got it all in this situation
yeah and frankly that d-line
is super deep especially with dexter
lawrence and leonard williams holding it
down they're wide receivers adding kenny
gallaudet
give a little protection for danny dimes
a little push for saquon
as an eagles fan that scares me with
that pick but now the eagles are up
pick number 12. who are you giving my
team connor
well now you can rejoice you got jalen
waddle you got the closest thing to
tyree kill we're gonna see
and waddle is once again somebody that
can really help out jalen hurts
he has rare on-field speed to run by
not one but two defenders he's the
classic definition of
i can take the top off the defense but
underneath
his transition from pass catcher to ball
carrier
is lightning fast he can make you miss
and you better not miss because he's
gone
if you do it's as simple as that they'll
work him on underneath routes
slants drag routes screens vertical
there's really no loss of speed whenever
he tries to change direction
he was one of the best special teams
players in the entire country
as a very young player as a sophomore on
a team where
you got to find your role you're sitting
behind jerry judy henry ruggs davonte
smith
and this guy still found a way to get on
the field
special speed let go and much more
polish not henry ruggs kind of speed but
more
smooth ready to play speed that means
the eagles would have jalen hurts
throwing to jaylen waddle and jalen
rhaegar
and i gotta say i kind of like it number
13
la chargers yeah jc horn
right here they need a corner right
they're a little thin at corner right
now
this is another team that they can go a
lot of directions they can continue to
beef up the offensive line for justin
herbert
i could have seen them taking waddle he
doesn't make it there go get yourself a
physical corner a guy that can press
a guy that stays in the hip pocket a
really a nightmare in the red zone he
gives receivers all kinds of fits
he can run with the mismatched players
in this division left though this is
thinking about
how do we stop darren waller how do we
stop travis kelsey
how do we stop noah fan you need players
that can do that jc horn can do that as
well so
for the chargers you're getting need but
you're also getting kind of the perfect
player to fit into this division
okay number 14 the minnesota vikings who
always seem to nail their first round
pick
who do you have them taken elijah vera
tucker from usc the best guard in this
draft he played left tackle last year
last year did it at a high level played
left guard the year before that
i like him at guard here for the vikings
you can play him at tackle if you need
to
just does everything right he reminded
me of david de castro a long time great
player for the steelers
somebody that has such a strong anchor
really really good feet
really good run blocker reliable and
pass pro
can get out in front and lead the way
can be a weapon as a puller
elijah vera tucker is quietly one of the
most underrated players in this class he
he probably ends up
overall when all is said and done to be
a top 10 player in this class he just
doesn't get that attention
because a lot of people view him as
guard and the vikings are so good
at capitalizing on value in the early
rounds each year
calvin cook another guy blocking the way
15 the new england patriots and there's
a big name that you still haven't said
is mac jones coming off the board right
here yeah and i got some explaining to
do with this one because
this is where mac jones should go is
what i think when you look at it it's
now new england will probably have to go
up to seven or eight or even maybe the
falcons trade again
to go get this one done because there'll
always be a sense of
urgency if mac jones or trey lance
whatever
quarterback number five starts to fall
but this is really where mac jones
should go he's a nice player
he could be a starter in this league a
pinpoint passer
good touch thrower as you see to the
corner of the end zone there
he has pretty good feel in the pocket
everybody raves about his iq
the mobility doesn't exist the play out
of structure it doesn't exist
but that's okay in the right offense and
in new england
i think things would work out for him
they've spent a lot of money on the
offense this year
we know they got nelson aguilar johnny
smith hunter henry
mack can be a really good middle of the
field thrower he's not someone in my
eyes that you're constantly gonna roll
out on booed action or get on the move
and ask him to throw
you want him as a pure pocket passer and
i know new england's running things a
little differently with cam newton but
for the future
they can build around mac and in this
situation it's not over scrutinized
there's not too much of a spotlight
he didn't turn into this top three pick
when he was regarded as a mid to late
first rounder for a long time
this is the right situation for all
parties involved
if this were to happen it is pretty
funny to me
that mac is almost bizarro cam not
mobile
super accurate pretty quiet you know
what cam
spelled backwards is mac
pretty interesting
mccorkle um 16.
arizona cardinals opened up everybody's
eyes this offseason when they added aj
green with kyler murray jj watt a lot of
free agents
16 right in the middle of this first
round where do they go
yeah well get ready for the offensive
line run it's already begun with vera
tucker now you get the second one and
tevin jenkins here after that first tier
of sewell and slater
kevin jenkins is just a bully he's a big
bad dude
he could play left tackle he could play
right tackle he could play guard if you
need him too
i just like arizona stacking the deck on
the offensive line and getting a little
nastier and i know they have kelvin
beechum there
kevin jenkins he can be he's just a
totally different animal in terms of a
run blocker he really is he reminds me
of taylor luann
uh just a bully he can climb he's a big
body but he's got good feet to get to
linebackers as you see right there
he's just really been lights out and
pass protection he got a lot
better this year before opting out and
he could take you for a ride in the run
game so i look at tevin jenkins and just
go man
he is way too good to fall outside the
top 20
and for arizona this is a little bit of
a more
safe pick but one you really really need
i know there's rumors them going up for
a big speedy wide receiver or things
like that
but just keep building the foundation in
front of kyler murray
and get a bookend that versatility is
the name of the game you heard it with
vera tucker you heard it with slater
these guys have played multiple spots on
the offensive line that's not easy to do
at a high level and they've done it
let's take a look at connor's picks from
9 to 16 as we finish off the top half of
the first round
nine jalen phillips goes to the falcons
after they trade back patrick certain to
the cowboys
rashawn slater offensive lineman to the
giants jalen
waddle to the eagles jc horror and
quarterback into south carolina to the
chargers
vera tucker to the vikings building out
that o-line
as we start that o-line run mac jones to
the patriots
tevin jenkins to the cardinals out of
oklahoma state connor who will get your
best grade in this section
probably rashaan slater to the giants
because he is such a good player
that is a gigantic need i just think
that fit there
it makes so much sense because he gives
you insurance for the future
but he also gives you instant impact
right now
so now we get to the raiders at 17.
lost a lot of offensive linemen we just
talked about the cardinals that's where
rodney hudson is now
which offensive lineman are you going
for the raiders because it's undoubtedly
their biggest need christian darasaw
just a player that is the dancing bear
no
man this size should be able to move
like him it's like lyell collins all
over again
i mean you see what he can do as a
puller to get to the outside it's
effortless
too it's kind of like i don't need to
put my full i don't need to generate
power from my lower body to move people
i could just shove them and it's really
hilarious to watch him play
to what he does the guys out in front i
mean really really a difference maker
because he
is he'll put up a zero in pass
protection and what i mean by that is
you wouldn't know he played no hurries
no hits
no sacks allowed that kind of guy and i
think
nfl coaches like john gruden can get
more out of him in the run game there's
more left
on the table with christian dara saw you
gotta capitalize on the offensive line
and the raiders they've done some
unconventional drafting in certain spots
over the years
but this is a great value pick all right
next up is the dolphins at 18 they took
kyle pitts at six who do you have them
taken here
they haven't been able to figure out
edge pass rusher recently so let's go
with aziz ogilari jalen phillips
from miami that would be an easy trip
for him he's gone so you go into zizo
jalari just head south
ogilari is a bryan flores guy like i've
told you before
lefko really the only recent redshirt
freshman in georgia history to be a
captain
all world worker strong for that 240
pound frame
good violent hands can work the outside
speed rush
good get off the snap can finish plays
and you see that little shoulder dip
for how muscular he is that is a hard
hard move to execute
and he does it over and over again so
ojalari can come in
set the tone for that locker room flores
will love him
he can get after the quarterback he's
stout against the run
he loves coming downhill and taking on
pulling guards just play some violent
brand of football
and this would be the guy they need at
outside linebacker or a little hand in
the dirt
in miami number 19
the washington football team what do you
got
you want to talk about value let's do
micah parsons at 19 for washington we
know the linebackers ron rivera has
coached in the past
and my comparisons to parsons if he
could fill out that potential
is luke keakley just a rare athlete in
the middle of the field he can rush the
passer
he can come downhill as a thumper
against the run he has the athleticism
to develop into a really good cover
player
we just haven't seen it yet because he
opted out last year
but i think it's all gonna come together
for him he's a really good
fiery player for the middle of the
defense and this is a need for
washington we
know how electric how talented that
front is they have a good secondary they
have a lot of pieces on offense for
fitzpatrick
but this is the need they have at
linebacker and they get
the top linebacker a top 10 player for
me in this draft
that is one of the more scary picks that
i've ever seen okay number 20 the
chicago bears what do you got greg
newsom they need a corner
and knew some local guy northwestern
talk about easy trips here
newsom can do it all he can press at the
line of scrimmage he has good instincts
in off man coverage
i think he plays the ball really really
well uh upright
frame you know i know they've watched
kyle fuller for a long time i've seen
some comparisons there
i think newsom's more like william
jackson the guy that washington just
gave
a lot of money to so you look at newsome
he's somebody that plays a physical
brand of football he does not lose the
catch point
they really didn't target him that much
he just doesn't allow
much room staying in the hip pocket of
wide receivers the only thing you have
to worry about with him and the only
reason he's available at 20 is
he's missed time due to injuries in all
three seasons as a starter so
that's the one lingering thing with
newsome but i think the talent is going
to outweigh the risk here
when it comes to the cults at 21 every
mock it's a pass rusher
because that's what they need so which
one are you picking for them
i'm going with quiddy pay now everybody
thinks they'll try to trade this pick i
don't know what partner is going to be
there for them to trade
just take the most talented edge pass
rusher you can
what i love about quiddy is he is a rare
rare athlete but he plays so
hard and he's still learning how to be a
pass rusher it's gonna take some time
to develop that pass rush plan but
that's okay because he's a non-stop
hustle player
off the field on the field i know people
won't get juiced up over this
comparison but he just got paid a lot of
money after a big year
right now he reminds me of trey
hendrickson he's somebody that can win
with the outside speed rush
very very twitched up but he can develop
into a lot more and you see that
you know hustle from the backside i just
look at quitty pay and think
he fits the identity of the players that
chris ballard and ed dodds they always
want
and i think he would come in and really
really take to coaching
and develop into the player everyone
expects him to be
all right we stay in the afc south for
22 it is the titans they lost a lot of
players
wide receiver tight end cornerback where
do they go here at 22.
they're gonna go terrace marshall they
need a big body target this is a player
that reminds me of denzel mims they lost
corey davis to free agency you got aj
brown
but ryan tannehill he needs these
contested catch players and what i love
about terrace marshall is
he's a big body player with a big catch
radius but this is what he can do
win vertically down the field run by
people
and win the football and he's got some
juice after the catch as well
so terrace marshall is somebody that is
not getting a lot of conversation
in 2019 sure he was that third guy
behind justin jefferson and jamar chase
he still caught a ton of touchdowns he
was the guy this year after chase opted
down jefferson left for the league
dominated the league
and he caught a million touchdowns again
so terrace marshall fits everything
tennessee likes
size speed catch radius contested catch
help out the quarterback he's a first
rounder in my eyes
your jets went zack wilson at two
who do they take at 23 a safe pick
they're going creed humphrey here now
this is tough for the jets you missed
out on darasaw
tevin jenkins and vera tucker that's not
what you want a lot of jets fans in
their eyes the backup plan
newsom he's gone too i can't say it
enough the board is going to break in a
tough way
at 23. creed humphreys that safe pick
this is kind of the nick mangold pick
all again this is coming full circle
here
you get a center that's played a million
snaps really good anchor
he can move in your outside zone rushing
attack
everybody loves this guy a rare athlete
at the center position
can climb to the second level doesn't
ever get beat on the interior which has
been a nightmare for the jets
for a long time now their guards and
centers have just gotten beat up over
the years
killing the young quarterback in sam
darnold so conor mcgovern moves over to
right guard
creed humphrey comes in and starts at
center now you're starting to see your
offensive line be fortified a little bit
this is a very very high floor pick and
joe douglas did not go that route last
year with mims or bechten
he didn't go that route early but he's
gonna play it safe a little bit here and
get
zach wilson some help in front of him
yeah creed humphrey and makai bechten
that's a little bit like your nick
mangold to brickishaw ferguson which is
what you want with a young quarterback
24 the steelers what a steelers pick you
got for me connor
yeah we did this one already naji harris
goes here and i know the steelers have
needs at offensive tackle and corner and
if you watch the dream draft from the
last draft crash course
they can fill those too now you get a
three down workhorse runner a little
stephen jackson a little matt forte
great pass catcher violent runner with
light feet
just not a lot of six foot two 230 pound
runners
that have this kind of feet and can
really give you problems in the second
level and third levels of the field
naji harris is plug and play you got to
help out big ben you need somebody that
can handle the ball
25 30 times a game combined through the
ground
through the air he he's really one of
the only runners in this class that's
going to come on the field
and play the bulk of the snaps because
what he can do in pass protection
what he can do as a route runner and
that workhorse
inside and outside all right that is
definitely gonna be a pick that's gonna
garner a lot of attention let's recap
pick
17 through 24 of connor rogers
mock draft as we get ready for the draft
on thursday night
christian daraso super athletic
alignment going to the raiders
aziz ogilari pass rusher going to the
dolphins
micah parsons the new league kick luke
keikley for ron rivera in washington
greg newsom ready to lock it down in
chicago
quitting pay the pass rusher for indy
terrace marshall jr
going to be lining up next to aj brown
creed humphrey
going to be the nick man gold for zach
wilson and naji harris
going to pittsburgh best grade here
connor
it's micah parsons to washington a top
10 player
best defender in the draft linebackers
tend to fall
a little bit so i it doesn't shock me if
he makes it here
he would be a superstar under ron rivera
left go
all right our last second pick
this is a team that has a multiple pick
in the first round the jacksonville
jaguars at 25 the last of the multiple
pick teams who were the jaguars taken
trayvon merrick from tcu a cover safety
he can play single high he could play
too high he can come down in the slot
we know what tennessee likes to do with
their tight ends
he can just handle a lot of different
roles for you and not a lot of safeties
can cover
like this guy i mean he like i've said
before it reminds me of justin reed who
you know jacksonville fans are very
familiar with in the division
just a very high iq player a good
tackler
adequate speed adequate range he just
does
everything the right way with ball
skills and he can come down with those
interceptions
breaks up passes jacksonville i think
you know we know what they're going to
do at number one
i think they're going to play it safe
here at 25 and either get themselves a
cover player for the back end
or if one of the offensive linemen falls
and in this case one did not
browns 26 what you got
maybe the biggest risk of the first
round and that's okay they're going to
take caleb farley here they have a need
at corner
and farley can be a top 10 player but
he had back spasms in 2019
did not play in 2020 and then needed a
back procedure before his
you know that ruined his pro day chances
but he
has all the talent in the world a player
that reminds me of marshawn lattimore
former high school quarterback
came to tech as a wide receiver or an
offensive skill player
it tours acl very very early there so
you see the injury history mounting up
but he was the best corner in this draft
before those injuries mattered i think
he had 24 passes broken up in only like
22 games something crazy
along those lines so the browns you have
a great roster
it one of the best in football right now
you don't have a lot of needs
you feel like you're ready to take the
next step you can swing for the fences
in this spot and bet on farley's talent
with the risk of the health and if that
secondary can get healthy from farley to
greedy williams to grant delpit
that's a future right there that if it
comes together could be pretty great
27 the ravens rashad bateman
minnesota and a player that just fits
this baltimore mold that wide receiver
he can catch in traffic
i thought he caught everything on the
2019 film some people are overreacting
to 2020 i thought the quarterback play
was abysmal
he's a tough player incredible releases
off the line of scrimmage
good route runner tracks the ball
extremely well the body control which
you see right there
i just look at bateman and think he fits
what this offense needs they had a tough
time in free agency trying to get a top
flight wide receiver to sign there
but guess what you could just draft one
in round one i think him and lamar
jackson would form a really really nice
connection in the short and intermediate
areas of the field
which is definitely something that they
are looking for you're right they could
not get a free agent other than sammy
watkins he'll join him
and hollywood brown 28 the saints
we're going to go wide receiver here and
we're going to go elijah moore this
gives them
some of that brandon cook's element
again the player that is
a little under size but can win down the
field really good speed
great routes look how quick he is left
go just lightning lightning
it's a tough year for michael thomas and
i don't know where the future of
this franchise is going to be with or
without them we know they're going to
try to make it work this year
but it doesn't matter where that's at
you still need a wide receiver across
from him
a player with a ton of experience in the
slot has won over the middle of the
field
very very good after the catch quietly
one of the best
separators in this entire draft elijah
moore
should be a round one pick and i think
this is great for the saints
i really think we're not talking about
it a lot but jameis winston gets the
opportunity there
they get a player like moore in round
one you have michael thomas bounce back
year
i think the saints would be really
exciting to watch even without drew
brees
yep they moved on from emmanuel sanders
so it'd be michael thomas
moore and then traequan smith number 30
the buffalo bills what a year they had
last year who do they take
well let's not forget about those green
bay packers at 29 left go i don't want
to forget about them
it's okay so we're getting wide receiver
number three in a row here rondelle
moore and a different player now we know
devonte adams is
all world that everything whether it's
catching the ball or dunking a
basketball it doesn't matter
but they need somebody else that could
do different things in this offense
rondell moore is one of the most
athletic players in this entire draft
class you can get those jet sweeps
working he can create his own yards on
screens
he'd be a dynamic slot weapon for aaron
rodgers
and if there's any space for him in the
field look out he's very very good at
breaking tackles
he's built like steve smith and that
competitive nature
to run through defenders reminds me of
steve smith
rondell moore is one of the more
interesting players in the draft
he comes in at five foot seven and
everybody's like are we overthinking
this guy
do not all the things he does best has
nothing to do with height
green base offense would be really
really scary if they can get
a player like this that can do some of
those randall cobb things we saw a long
time ago that might not matter in this
offense anymore but at a much more
electric level
a weapon for rogers in the first round
that might be too optimistic okay now
the buffalo bills at 30 my apologies
it's okay they need a lot of juice off
the edge here and they're going to take
a risk here it's going to be jason away
from penn state
a player that is a little too rich for
my blood to go in round
one but i think he's going there and
that's why i wanted him in this mock is
to prepare people to think he could
sneak in
the bills are an interesting spot they
need a speedster running back that could
go etn they need help on the edge away
would not surprise me a hand in the dirt
defensive end that
his best football should be ahead of him
just a dynamic dynamic athlete
incredible speed he's got that hustle
against the run that we know the bill's
defensive staff
loves so this would take some developing
but they are one of the best staffs in
football
at developing talent so i like this fit
for both sides
and i think for the bills edge pass rush
is just a little bit
important than getting a running back
here and i know they have a talented
roster where they can take that round
one running back and it might not hurt
them like it does
a lot of teams typically but i'd rather
take your swing
get a little bit more juice off the edge
and a player that
there's so much untapped potential in
his pass rush game
i love it add him do a d line with jerry
hughes get a little mentoring there and
then also possibly replace
down the line 31 the kansas city
chiefs where are we going with this team
man
they need help at offensive tackle and
i'm going to take alex leatherwood
somebody that's played guard and tackle
at alabama at a very high level
good athlete long long arms
plays with an edge can move people off
the snap as a drive blocker
but like i said enough enough
athleticism to do a lot of different
things whether you want him to pull
whether you want him out front on
screens or whether you just want to
trust him to keep patrick mahomes
upright i think that's a good idea as
well so
i think the chiefs are in a in a
situation where
they just got to take whatever best
offensive lineman is on the board
and maybe they get aggressive to do that
but i think you could sit tight
and get one whether it's leatherwood
cosmi
eichenberg they just got to take an
offensive tackle they feel good about
protecting mahomes
but i value leatherwood because what he
can also bring in the run game as well
after the super bowl all of us want
patrick mahomes to have more time
in the pocket 32 super bowl champion
tampa bay bucks
yeah a team that does not have a lot of
needs and i'm gonna go christian barmore
the defensive tackle from alabama
that's one area where you could see down
the road they're gonna need some help
and todd bowles does a nice job
rotating his defensive players enough
where those violent hands that pass rush
juice that good get off of bar more for
a big body can come into play here now
i don't think this is a good defensive
line class overall on the interior not
on the edge on the interior it's a
little thin
i think bar more is going round one i
might not value him as a round one
player
but i think a team is going to look at
him and go man he was a superstar in the
college football playoff
that's when he played his best football
he finally looked healthy
i think for the bucks they're in a
situation where
they can do a lot of different things
just because they don't have that many
needs
but i think bowles will always have a
voice in that room
and he's always going to speak up to
beef up that defensive line
hey adam avita veya and domikin soo let
him learn from them
i love it let's recap 25
excuse me 32 marig the safety goes to
the jaguars caleb farley
corner goes to the browns rashad bateman
a weapon for lamar to the ravens
another wide receiver elijah moore to
the saints another wide receiver
the short bit impactful rondelle moore
to the packers
jason away edge not a lot of production
but a lot of potential goes to the bills
alex leatherwood big time tackle going
to the chiefs
and christian bar more defensive tackle
to the bucks
best grade here connor i'm going to say
rashad bateman to the ravens i think
he's a top 20 player i think they need a
wide receiver
i think he's going to surprise a lot of
people as a rookie because he's so pro
ready lefko that he'll come in and it
doesn't matter the situation
he would take advantage of those targets
and really thrive
all right that was our final show the
mock draft thank you guys for joining us
along this draft crash
crash course thursday night me connor
akeeb to leave
rg3 cam jordan a whole lot of people
it's gonna be absolutely phenomenal
that will be day one and day two day
three conor's gonna be there
with taylor rooks and a number of
special guests and don't forget
post your reactions after your team
drafts
put them in the nfl draft community on
the br app
and we will send you some swag connor
any
final message before we get to the nfl
draft
man i can't wait dude it's just going to
be it's going to be like the
version of this just the premium the
premium
every pick graded we're going to spend
way more time on all
of the picks we're going to talk about
the prop bets
it's just going to be a blast man i
cannot wait for a week from now
connor you are the man i love you i
cannot wait to see it it's going to be
awesome can't wait to get you down here
in atlanta to everybody out there for
connor rogers
um left go we will hala halahala at you
later
see